قال منسق الاتصالات الاستراتيجيه في مجلس
الامن القومي الامريكي جون كيربي ان
الرئيس بايدن لا يزال متفائلا بامكانيه
التوصل لحل الدولتين الذي يحقق مصلحه
الشعبين الفلسطيني والاسرائيلي اضاف كيربي
في حديث لشبكه ان بي سي الاخباريه
الامريكيه ان بايدن يتعامل مع نتنياهو
كرئيس وزراء منتخب لكن هذا لا يعني عدم
وجود خلافات حول السياسات بين الرجلين حسب
تعبيره
لا يزال الرئيس بايدن متفائلا جدا بشان
امكانيه تحقيق حل الدولتين ويعتقد انه
الطريق الامثل للمضي قدما نحو تحقيق
السلام والامن في المنطقه بالتاكيد سيعود
ذلك بفائده كبيره على الشعب الفلسطيني لكن
الرئيس يعتقد ايضا ان حل الدولتين يصب في
مصلحه الشعب الاسرائيلي والان لدينا
نتنياهو وهو رئيس وزراء اسرائيل المنتخب
ونحن نحترمه والرئيس بايدن يعرفه وعمل معه
منذ وقت طويل لكنهما بالتاكيد لا يتفقان
في كل جوانب السياسه ورغم ذلك لن يتردد
الرئيس في تصميمه على تحقيق تقدم على طريق
حل الدولتين